my guy Timur from the Windy City of
Chicago
I heard that you are a barber before
he's our door comedy which I feel like
is is a cheating thing behind your beard
cuz you knew how to manufacture two beer
that's another that's another story
what was that like for you I mean from a
material basis you know the barber shop
is a comedy hub do you feel like that
was a place where where you perfected
your craft and a barber shop while he
was cutting here honestly yes I mean
it's a haven for comedy man I mean I was
one of those barbers like if you come to
the barber shop you've all had the
barber that spend more time cracking
jokes 100% didn't cutting hair yes I
want to have two hours you don't get a
whole comedy show while you wait on this
line that's a good thing though the
barber shop is honestly the best comedy
club I think Mac's going into the barber
shop you know on on a weekend and having
a high level of chemistry with everybody
in there that's a good Saturday it is
snapping with everybody in the shop now
because you were a comedian that people
find themselves snapping at you more do
you feel like oh all the time yeah you
know cats coming to barber shop they
feel like they can take you yeah they
come in they just want a roast and then
when you go in on them you know anal
security to break it up
no no so you know you go in on and you
rose from some people feelings get her
ie you notice enough with all they leave
joke oh I got a photo I want you to
explain a photo to me okay uh-huh
what was going on okay so those are my
first headshots okay right so after I
started doing stand-up comedy everybody
you know you got to get a headshot okay
and I was like okay cool I'm a-gonna
headshot
so when I went in I went to this
photographer who was generally took
photos of children okay
I didn't know I didn't know that you
needed to get a photographer they
focused on you know I guess you and your
age and what was going on oh so I went
to this a lot of things is wrong with
this picture I would tell you you should
have knew it was bad when he said go go
get your bike you are more than ready
for this moment man this is the next
level for you go out there and go make
Chicago proud
y'all shoulders Manson love right now
[Applause]
[Music]